Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and hopefully
you’ve all had a chance to see Guardians
of the Galaxy.
Definitely one of if not the most fun Marvel
movie so far.
They already confirmed there’s a sequel
coming out July 2017 so this video is going
to be the top 5 stories I think they should
do.
If you’re just finding me for the first
time I do Marvel videos every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And yes, I’m totally doing videos for all
the Marvel tv shows when they get here.
Here’s something funny to think about.
This past weekend Guardians made about 165
Million Dollars worldwide, so if you were
James Gunn you would probably celebrate by
taking a vacation right?
Well he actually spent the weekend starting
work on Guardians 2.
He’s going to be writing and directing again.
He didn’t just do that, he also ate a lot
of candy and talked with a lot of fans on
twitter.
That sounds like something I would do.
Just start working on my next video and tweet
funny gifs of dancing baby groots.
There were so many easter eggs during the
movie that I feel like half of my list is
a no-brainer.
So Here’s my top 10 stories I think they
should do for Guardians 2.
But careful for spoilers in case you haven’t
seen it yet.
Because I’ll be talking about specific things
from the story.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay?
Everybody Read?
Here we go.
Number 5 - The Universal Church of Truth tries
to cleanse the Galaxy of impurity and bring
back the Magus, the evil future version of
Adam Warlock.
He’s a big character himself, so he shows
up in various ways on this list, but just
like Ronan was the main villain in Guardians
and Thanos was on the periphery.
Think of a Church of Truth story as being
all about their conquest.
There’s only a couple of paths a sequel
can take, it can go bigger and up the stakes,
it can go smaller and go deeper into a specific
character or it can be a time travel story,
which is also kind of an alternate universe
story depending on how the outcome is altered.
I’ll talk more about time travel in the
marvel universe in a sec.
But doing a story with the Church would be
an escalation.
In the comics Adam Warlock at a certain point
absorbed himself into the soul gem to prevent
a future where he turned into his evil self,
the Magus.
The Church wants the Magus to come.
So they could always go on a galactic crusade
to find the soul gem and unleash Adam Warlock’s
darker self.
There are a couple of things that would make
this difficult.
Mostly that Adam Warlock was an easter egg
in the post credits scene from Thor The Dark
World.
That cocoon in the background, that’s Adam
Warlock’s cocoon.
In Guardians of the Galaxy’s post credits
scene, the collector’s cases are all shattered.
The cocoon from Dark World is broken.
Meaning whatever was inside escaped.
The tease being that Adam Warlock is out in
the Marvel Universe wandering around now free
to be used as a character the movies.
Marvel actually put a company wide bad on
using the character in the comics after Annihilation
War but I don’t remember ever seeing a reason.
Number 4 - Korvac Saga (Time Gem)
This is a time travel story, but they could
alter it a little.
I don’t think any future Guardians sequel
will feature another Gem.
I think we’ll see the Gauntlet in the next
Thor movie but we have no idea where the Time
Gem is.
Either it will show up in Avengers Age of
Ultron or some other characters movie in Phase
3.
Michael Korvac came back in time and assimilated
all of Galactus’ knowledge giving him these
godlike powers.
He tries to remake the earth as a new utopia
but the Avengers and the Guardians of the
Galaxy team up to stop him.
It’s one of those predestination paradox
stories whereby at the end he sends his consciousness
to the future that he originally came from
setting off a chain of events that caused
him to travel back in time in the first place.
So it’s like this never ending loop of causality.
This seems a little too complicated for a
Marvel movie, so think of it as Korvac gaining
ultimate knowledge and the Guardians having
to team up with a few new characters and Benecio
Del Toro’s character to take them down.
They kind of did this in the first movie,
but in the Korvac saga.
Del Toro’s character, the Collector sends
his daughter to help the guardians.
Number 3 - Marvel The End
This is a Thanos centric story and I hope
that if anything the sequel at least goes
deeper into his character.
A group of celestial beings learn to harness
this power called the heart of the universe.
It’s like a higgs boson situation whereby
everything that exists in the universe flows
from this power source.
Things go sideways and in order to stop them,
Thanos absorbs the power into himself becoming
one with the universe.
He learns that everything is doomed to die
because of a fatal flaw in the structure of
reality and the only way to fix it is to reboot
the universe.
He gets pissed but the aspect of death and
Adam Warlock convince him to do the right
thing.
He reboots the universe but erases himself
from existence in the process.
This story is different from the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline in that all the gems just
make thanos more powerful.
When he absorbs the heart of the universe
he himself becomes one with everything.
All the cosmic beings of the universe like
Eternity, Infinity, Death, Galactus, they
all just become part of him.
Here’s how they could do this story in a
vastly simpler way.
The take the part about Thanos wanting to
fix the flaw in the structure of the universe
and make it part of his backstory.
Like his quest for the gems just becomes part
of an ongoing quest for him to fix everything
by destroying it and rebooting.
I’m going to save the universe by blowing
it up.
It sounds like a Doctor Who story.
Which is why they probably won’t do it.
Number 2 - The Cull Obsidian also known as
the Midnight Slaughter
This is a group of lieutenants that Thanos
assembles in the recent Infinity storyline
from last year.
It’s Corvus Glaive, Proxima Midnight, Supergiant,
Black Dwarf and Ebony Maw.
Internally they call themselves the Black
Order and each member is called a Dreadlord.
In the movies so far we’ve only met The
Other who’s actually played by Alexis Denisoff,
cool whedonverse fact.
And now in guardians, Nebula.
Although just like Gamora it seems like she
split on him too.
It would be pretty cool to see Thanos assemble
his own evil Avengers.
I don’t know that a single movie could handle
that many characters, considering you already
have the five Guardians characters returning.
Thanos will eventually have to replace Gamora
and Nebula on his team though.
Number 1 - Thanos Backstory in combination
with a few other big stories
Usually what ends up happening is marvel movies
take pieces of different stories and use them
together.
So I’d really like to see a deep cut on
Thanos that spells out his past so that when
we do get to Avengers 3, we don’t have to
spend half the movie explaining why he’s
assembling the gems.
So combine his backstory with war of kings,
minus the shi’ar, because Fox has rights
to them and add in Adam Warlock as like an
anti-thanos storyline that dovetails with
the next Avengers movie.
So you see the rise of these two celestial
beings and the Guardians get caught between
them in the middle of a giant galactic race
war.
That actually sounds like Game of Thrones
in space.
Which is a good reason why they will probably
do something way simpler.
Movie plots tend to be pretty linear.
So no Game of Thrones.
And probably no infinity gem.
It’s pretty obvious that they will do more
Thanos and Peter Quill’s Father.
After that all bets are off.
When Glenn Close said Quill came from something
ancient.
She was talking about an ancient race.
His father is Jason of Spartax, emperor of
the Spartoi.
They’re a cousin race to the Shi’ar.
Since the Shi’ar are an X-Men universe race,
that means Fox owns their rights.
Which might cause Marvel to alter Peter Quill’s
backstory a little in the movies.
Until we get confirmation let’s assume it
will be the same as it is in the comics though.
It’s likely that Quill will have to get
his father’s help to fight Thanos eventually.
Like use the Spartoi fleet the way they got
the Nova Corps to help out.
That whole scene where Glenn Close mentions
his genetics is a bit weird.
I mean, the Spartoi aren’t a secret race,
if the Nova Corps knows what an infinity gem
is, then why can’t their super machine identify
Spartoi DNA?
I don’t want to poke too many holes or anything,
but that did bug me a little.
They might change it and make Peter Quill’s
father a celestial being like Thanos.
Thanos isn’t a celestial, but he descends
from a celestial race.
So for all intents and purposes he is a super
being.
Interesting fact: In the comics, Peter Quill’s
grandfather is named Eson of Spartax as in
Eson the Searcher.
it’s a different character, but they could
use that fact to connect Peter Quill to the
celestials in the movie.
But let me know what story from the comics
you want to see them use.
Don’t forget that they’ll probably chop
up a bunch of stories and use different bits.
And do you think that they’ll change Peter
Quill’s father and make him a celestial?
My next Marvel video will probably be for
Avengers 2.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Now that Guardians is slowly going away we
can start focusing on Age of Ultron.
Right now click here for my Guardians review
in case you haven’t seen it and click here
for a breakdown of the Avengers 2 trailer
at comic con.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!